welcome back now a poll last week
suggested that the conservatives are
narrowly beating labor for second place
in Scotland with Holyrood elections just
three months away if correct it would be
a huge turnaround for the two parties in
a further sign of Labor's fall from
grace north of the border land joined
now by the leader of the Scottish
conservators Ruth Davidson she's in
Edinburgh and a very good morning to you
well I mentioned there the fairly Rosie
bowls in terms of the Scottish
conservatives but presumably you are not
counting any chickens absolutely no I
mean we've had four pools by four
different pollsters with four different
methodologies since the turn of the year
each and every one of shoulder record
high in Holyrood voting intentions for
the Scottish conservatives and that's
nice but we've still got 87 days to go
until pools open and the other thing
that all of these polls shoulders was
actually there's a very big lead over
the SNP over everybody else and my job
is to make sure I put forward a a a
proper policy platform that shows that
we can really hold the SMP to account we
can put forward a positive alternative
future for Scotland and they will look
after family finances when you taxpayer
has come to the building behind me here
but you have said that you think you
will do better in Holyrood than you have
done before so from the previous high
watermarks you're talking about 20 plus
seats well I'm not going to put our
ceiling on my ambition dammit and you
wouldn't expect me to but yes we are a
party that's on the off by charge by my
team my candidates all of the people
that are working with me my activists to
go out and get us the best Scottish
Conservative result that we've ever had
in the history of devolution were on
course to achieve that but of course
that's only part of the picture the rest
of the picture is who makes up the rest
of the Scottish Parliament I stand ready
to make a strong contribution in the
next parliament I think there's lots of
issues in Scotland that we need to
resolve not least the flirtation the SNP
keep to continue having with the second
referendum we had a referendum it was in
September 2014 as long as they talked up
for independence i will speak up for the
two million voters in scotland that said
no thank you we want to remain part of
the united kingdom and we also want our
two governments and scotland to work
together and not have this synthetic
grudge and grievance that's continually
perpetrated
perpetuated by the SNP and thrown into
this mix is the potential some say
probability of an EU referendum in June
on june the 23rd where do you stand and
of course the First Minister from
Scotland nicola sturgeon and indeed
others have said well it's kind of
muddying the waters if you do try to
hold it then because of these may
elections it's too soon where do you
stand on that but you know Scotland
already has four different voting
systems for the European Parliament the
Westminster Parliament the Scottish
Parliament and local authorities were
quite a sophisticated electorate and
indeed at the last Scottish
parliamentary election in 2011 we had a
referendum on the same day that was on
the AV system of voting and if Nicola
Sturgeon thinks that Scottish waters
aren't smart enough to be able to think
of more than one thing at a time and
I've got news for her it also seems to
do down her argument because that was
the election when they also had the
referendum that the SMP got the majority
and so you know I think it may be does a
disservice to the voters of Scotland to
think that people here can't think of
more than one thing at a time I what do
you think of the prime minister's city
you renegotiations of course you've
always said you'd be voting to stay in
whatever he got has he done enough do
you feel to satisfy the the rest the
entirety of the Conservative Party well
you're right to say that I came out very
early last summer I went over to
Brussels and made a speech about how I
thought it was in Scotland's interest to
stay part of the United Kingdom for me I
also explained that there was an
unbalanced approach this isn't like the
independence referendum from you which
touched me very deeply and it touched
ideas of both national identity and
personal identity I you know I don't
think anybody goes to sleep under you
know a european flag duvet cover and no
matter where you live in the country and
for me this just isn't as big or as
primacy of an issue for me and however i
think people at home should remember
when they are casting their ballot
whether that's in junior at some other
time that this is on whether we stay
part of the united kingdom or not this
isn't a referendum on on the Prime
Minister's negotiations Percy oh I'm
glad to see that he's continuing all of
his work particularly again this week
going to Poland going to Denmark so to
try and keep improving the deal that we
have in Europe you know what ever going
to get everything are we were one member
of a 28
member organization I think it's naive
to suggest we get everything that we
wanted but I do think on balance and for
me it's not balanced decision we're
better off it but you talk there about
how important the you is to Scotland and
indeed about the independence referendum
would though the SNP not have a case as
they've often said that if brexit is the
overall results in the United Kingdom
and Scotland within that voted to stay
there would be a case for another
independence referendum to their
ultimately allow Scotland to remain
within the European Union Derek there's
hardly a day or a week that goes by
without a senior member of the SNP
saying that some things an indirect to
trigger if I had a pound for every time
somebody in their party had said that
I'd be a very rich lady indeed everybody
across Scotland knows that the United
Kingdom is the member states of the
European Union it is up for individual
members in a referendum where
everybody's vote counts the same to cast
that ballot as they saw please and I
have a sneaking suspicion that actually
you won't see too much difference on
either side of the border on this one
yeah but you know you've said it there
yourself haven't you if there were a
vote to leave the European Union you'd
be dragged kicking and screaming out of
the European Union as well I didn't say
I was kicking and screaming as I said
that for me this didn't matter anywhere
near as much as the independence
referendum that I thought it was an
unbalanced decision I think the United
Kingdom is one of the g7 largest
economies in the world it may have a
short to medium-term detriment to us but
I think in the longer term as an economy
of our size and an economy that is
growing faster than every other major
economy in the world for the last two
years was it the hard work of George
Osborne and of course we would be able
to survive outside the European Union I
mean I also was tried to be recruited
you know for the inners campaign Botha
when they were setting up the the board
for the the mainland campaign I I had a
couple of approaches and I turned them
down I had an approach from number 10 to
be in the sorry approach from within the
Conservative Party itself to be in the
kind of Tories foreign campaign and I
turned that down because I have bigger
issues on my plate right now I have 97
days until the polls open in Scotland
and I know what my job is my job is to
make sure that we return a big cohort of
conservative MSPs behind me that we're
able to stand strong against
any idea of a second referendum here in
Scotland that we can look out for the
family finances of workers install and
when new taxpayer has come to the
Scottish Parliament and we can hold the
SMP to account because for nine years
I've been sitting in that chamber behind
me and I've watched the official
opposition the Labour Party not lay a
glove on the SMP their shambolic they're
not been tremendously competent I think
if something in Scotland needs to change
and if the the voters of Scotland choose
not to change the government in Scotland
then I think they should change the
official opposition and I stand ready to
serve all right okay I ask you as you
describe their building this
compassionate progressive brand of
conservatism in Scotland and looking
after the interests of working people
where does the the Chancellor's deal
with companies like Google working all
that I made a speech at the David humans
to shoot last week a lecture series that
they have right I talked a little bit
about that and I said that you know it's
one of those situations where you see
and you ask companies like Google or
Apple or others and they say well look
we paid what HMRC asked us to we've paid
within the law we paid what we would you
and you say to the government and and
you know David Cameron George Osborne
others quite rightly see we're doing
more to count to crack down on tax
avoidance than anybody else in the past
we're going after companies that the
Labour Party left alone for years and
didn't pay any tax ation at all and both
of these answers are right but for
people out there doesn't feel right
doesn't feel fair it doesn't feel when
you're looking at the right hand side of
your own paycheck and you're seeing the
money that's coming off it doesn't feel
fair that all these multinational
conglomerates seem to be paying much
less than you do so yeah I want to see
big companies across this country across
all countries paying their fair share
but I don't want to see them picking up
their skirts on and moving to other
country so I think there's a real ?
there over how we increase the fairness
that people see out there and i also
think if i thought might expand this for
a second and i think it adds to this
sense i'm sorry it just adds to the
sense that we're seeing of a disconnect
between people in countries and the
governments of countries as well it
makes it feel as if the government's are
letting people off with things and
that's why I think you see the rise of
the sort of populist movements that
we've seen in green
that we're seeing in France that we're
seeing even with Trump in the United
States and I think there is a real worry
in a real danger I mean to give serious
thoughts of these issues